projects
hey guys some of you asked me to make a
video on relationship advice for men
now some of you watching this video
might think man I don't need any
relationship advice it's easy I know
what I'm doing
just thinking that probably shows that
you do need relationship advice
think about it think about this
seriously how do you have and sustain a
successful healthy beautiful marriage
how do you have a true relationship of
love the kind of relationship everyone
wants to have but so feel really fine
what is the secret
the answer is not found in only one
thing but many things many little things
put together
that is why so many relationships today
fail because a lot of people just want
quick fixes
and that's the problem when it comes to
relationships why
because there are no quick fixes in
relationships it takes time patience and
most of all hard work
listen to this that which you work the
hardest for are also the things you will
appreciate the most in your life
now there are many things that we can
talk about but let me only give you 10
points 10 things that will help you to
have a successful healthy beautiful
relationship that you will treasure
until the day you die
number one
get out if you don't want to marry
if you are in a relationship and you
know man I don't really want to marry
this girl then what are you doing
you are a time bomb waiting to cause a
lot of pain only get into a relationship
if you believe
that you want to marry this girl
because if you don't then you are
wasting a lot of time and
you're also going to cause a lot of hurt
many people go into one relationship
after the other and in the end they
carry all that baggage with them into
the next one causing more harm and more
damage
then if you're unsure you need to look
out for those warning signs that show
you you probably should not marry her
for example
she does not respect you in front of
other people she always thinks she is
right and never apologizes she does not
have the same beliefs as you do she does
not take responsibility for her own
actions she always screams and walks
away when she has a conflict with
someone instead of calmly talking things
out now of course this is not easy
because people are not perfect but still
you need to keep your eyes out for
certain signs that shows you man these
signs are just getting more and more and
more and more and this is important
because remember if you marry her
you're going to spend the rest of your
life with her and not just that marriage
is not just about you
but about the family and your kids
so ask her her views when it comes to
raising children or how to work with
money these are some of the things that
couples argue about the most and a
marriage can either be very very
beautiful amazing or it can almost be
like hell on Earth so make sure you talk
about these important issues before
marriage
let me just say this again while you
look for those signposts those warning
signs
always remember that people are not
perfect so if you're looking for the
perfect woman you'll never find her
because you yourself are not perfect but
there are definitely certain types of
girls that will not be a great fit for
you
be unselfish
true love is not selfish
look around you look at the world people
have become very selfish in almost
everything they do and that is why so
many people struggle to have good
relationships for some reason people
think that if they put themselves first
you know they will be more happier but
it's actually the opposite the more they
put themselves first the more selfish
they become the more they push other
people away and the more unhappier they
become not just unhappy but lonely
C.S Lewis said love is unselfishly
choosing for another's highest good this
type of love is not a Feeling
that means in our situations when you
don't feel like loving the other person
you still love them because it's a
decision that you make so love is not a
feeling this true love agape love is not
a feeling it is an act of your will so
even when you are in a disagreement you
can choose to be unselfish and love the
other person
a lot of people when it comes to
relationships that only focus on the
Eros love which means romantic love but
they don't have the agapella which is
the unconditional love the love that's
not a feeling but an active decision a
choice that you make that you love the
other person even when you don't feel
like it and that is why so many
relationships fail because they only
focus on the Eros love but ask any
person who's been married for a few
years
if you only focus on era's love your
marriage will fail you need
unconditional love agape love to carry
you through
look your best I really mean look your
best your physical appearance for some
reason a lot of guys when they get
married they stop caring about the way
they look why
you have to have enough respect for
yourself to take care of yourself eat
healthy stay in shape cut your hair
style it
trim your beard put on the right outfits
for the right occasions and just look
good for her why so that she can see
that you're putting in the effort to
look good for her so that she can see
that you're not lazy so that she can see
that you respect yourself enough and her
as well so that you take care of
yourself do I need to go on
you are not giving it your best in a
relationship if you're not even trying
to really look good you need to do your
best when it comes to looking
presentable unattractive for your own
wife keep that spark alive
say I'm sorry a lot of guys don't want
to say they're sorry because for some
reason they think they will look weak
when they do it
but it doesn't take strength
it's it's easy to not say you're sorry
to be full of Pride that's super easy it
is hard it takes a lot more strength as
a man to say I'm sorry for me this is
not even difficult anymore because when
you're wrong you're wrong take
responsibility for your actions
everything you say and everything you do
full stop if you're wrong about
something you need to apologize
and how can you expect her to apologize
to you when you don't do it you can't
expect that from her and here's the
problem
in those kind of relationships where
both parties they don't want to take
responsibility they don't want to say
they're sorry that kind of relationship
will never work it is impossible
give each other space
if you are a Clinger very clingy then
you need to hear this today some people
when they marry they cling so tightly to
their partner that they start to think
all the happiness and joy should come
from their partner so they cling so
tightly that they suffocate their
partner
no your partner is not responsible for
your joy for your happiness you are you
are responsible for your own actions the
way you think about things you need to
take responsibility for your own life
not only is it wrong to be super clingy
and expect everything from your partner
that they should give you everything and
then you'll be happy not only is it
wrong it is selfish
it is always better to give than to
receive
and that is especially true when it
comes to relationships
answer me truthfully how many times do
you think men
she should do this for me or no she
should do this better oh no she should
change she should do this how many times
are you thinking that instead of
thinking man I wonder what she needs
from me right now
and that's the problem you see when both
parties think man she should give me
this or he should give me that one they
both just need things the whole time
instead of just giving to each other
what they both need
instead of thinking I want want want
think
what does she want what does she need
both parties need to think like that and
then you'll have a happy successful
relationship
be quiet and just hug her
you don't always need to be right you
don't always need to win the argument
because what sense is there what you
know there's nothing Smart in that to
win the argument but then you lose the
person you lose her in the process
please don't be that person who never
listens who always talks over your wife
and who just wants to always voice your
opinion while having no interest in
really understanding her
women are different they are not lie
guys sometimes she doesn't need a
rational solution to her problem she
just need you to listen and to hug
that's it
women are like that but the worst thing
that you can do is to be unwilling to
listen to talk over her and you just
want to voice your own opinion an old
Wise book said this
a fool takes no pleasure in
understanding but only in expressing his
opinion
do you know this book it's called the
Bible
you need to read it a little bit more
are you a fool
I hope not because why would you be a
fool why would you act like a fool to
the one that you're supposed to love
make the effort
the effort of what of everything keep
the spark alive keep the fire alive at
all times take her on dates get the
flowers tell her how much she means to
you talk to her with love and respect
make her coffee
open the door for her and praise her in
front of other people should I go on
listen carefully you should never do it
just because you want to receive it back
from her you do it
with the intention of doing it because
you love her and you don't want to
receive anything back if you treat her
as a queen
she will treat you as a king
never give up
believe me there will be times where she
will let you down and where you will let
her down why because we are humans we
have a sinful nature within us we are
not perfect and we make mistakes so it
will happen and when it does happen
don't give up don't fight don't argue
control your emotions sit down and talk
it out like adults you married her she
is the woman you chose so never give up
on her because it might be easy to give
up but the regret that comes after that
will not be easy to handle so forgive
each other understanding that you are
not perfect learn from the mistakes and
then move on grow from it
speak less and listen more
how well do you really know her do you
truly make the time to listen to her her
desires her needs her dreams her ideas
her favorite things to do her plans her
everything
some guys just speak too much and they
don't listen
but when you speak so much you talk so
much to her you just tell her what you
already know and think but you don't
learn anything
when you listen that is the time when
you actually learn new things about her
understand your role as a good husband
some of you might not have had a great
example because you grow up without a
father so you a little bit unclear Some
of you might have had a father
but he was not a great husband so you're
also a little bit uncertain and some of
you might have a father who is great but
there's still room to grow and you know
yourself there's still room to grow but
then there are some guys who think I
know how to be a great husband I know
exactly you are probably the most
dangerous because that just shows
that you are not perfect because no
human being especially men are perfect
we are not perfect and there's always
room to grow and if we think that we
know everything that means that we think
we don't need to grow that means we will
be stuck in life
and that means that we have an ego
problem a pride problem oh no I'm
perfect
pride and ego oh those things will
destroy a marriage
you need to be open to learn and to grow
because it will never stop
C.S Lewis said mere change is not growth
growth is the synthesis of change and
continuity and where there is no
continuity there is no growth
to boost your relationship to have a
successful healthy relationship you need
to understand what true love really is
and most people today sadly they don't
understand what true love really is
because we are flawed people living in a
flawed world but if you want to know you
want to learn you want to grow first
understand what true love is
watch this video here from my other
channel and I'll see you there and
before you go always remember life is
short
so don't waste yours cheers guys